estimated 50 000 migrants seeking Asylum
or waiting in Mexico now planning to
cross the border as soon as title 42
ends and the number of illegal Crossings
could double or even triple in the
coming days with no clear plan for the
administration to stem the tide Senator
John Kennedy saying Republicans have
lost trust in the willingness of the
White House to secure the Border amid
record legal illegal Crossings
the president ought to hide his head on
the back I mean it's clear that he and
the members of the administration of the
administration are perfectly content to
have an open board all President Biden
needs to do in order to secure the
Porter is go back doing what we were
doing
the militia is live in Eagle Pass Texas
and I'm sure that the local community is
bracing itself for what's to come bill
Dana they are good morning to you and as
usual as soon as the sun came up this
morning we started getting Mass illegal
Crossings here we'll take you live to
our Fox drone right now just a couple
miles away from where I'm standing right
now in Eagle Pass it is over a group of
several hundred who have just crossed
illegally and are standing around
waiting for processing and transport by
border patrol you can see the river off
to the right where they've crossed into
is a private pecan Orchard this is
private property that is why the state
of Texas put up a chain-link fence there
but it's not really stopping them once
they cross the river they just climb
over it or they walk through it and you
can see the amount of resources that
have to respond to a group like this
we'll show you the group as it was
walking up take a look at this piece of
video our team shot again just after
Sunrise we'll see the the low sunlight
there as this group walks past that
chain link fence it's predominantly
Cubans nicaraguans and Colombians
crossing here in this sector most of
them not subject to title 42 and a CBP
Source tells Fox News this Del Rio
sector which includes Eagle Pass is
already seen over 115
000 excuse me illegal cross things just
since October 1st those numbers are up
56 percent over the same time last year
and last year set the all-time record
for illegal Crossings in this sector so
we're already on track to blow that
record out of the water just two and a
half months into this new fiscal year
then we'll take you out to Yuma Arizona
take a look at this photo uh border
patrol agents in the open desert east of
Yuma patrolling fine two abandoned
backpacks on the ground and in those
backpacks full of meth 90 pounds of meth
worth over a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars on the streets obviously dropped
and abandoned by suspected drug
smugglers highlighting the fact that
there are illegal immigrants trying to
backpack this stuff into our country
then we'll take you out to the Tucson
sector take a look at these wild photos
agents pulled over a vehicle near Wilcox
Arizona after it tried to circumvent a
checkpoint on the highway inside they
find nine illegal immigrants all piled
on top of each other in this little SUV
being smuggled there were two U.S
citizens driving that vehicle they were
both arrested and charged with human
smuggling and then lastly we'll take you
out to the Tucson sector again near Ajo
Arizona where agents encountered four
separate groups totaling nearly 350
people but what makes these photos
interesting is all the people you're
seeing here they were from 12 different
countries around the world nearby Yuma
sector just had five groups from 46
countries around the world so just goes
to show people are coming in from all
over the place and then lastly back out
here live border patrol in the Rio
Grande Valley announcing late yesterday
afternoon that their agents arrested two
illegal immigrants with murder
convictions including one who was
convicted of murdering a peace officer
in Los Angeles and another who was
convicted of murder in the state of
Virginia and guys that is why it is so
important to have agents out on the
front lines and why it is so concerning
when we had more than 73 000 known
gotaways at our border last month alone
we'll send it back to you Bill I have a
quick question for you so you know we've
been uh talking to you every day or if
it's Griff or Alexis or Nate whoever is
down on the border for us reporting
every single day often you're the only
reporter down there it looks to be that
that's perhaps changing it a little bit
do you get the sense that they
understand the other media that
understands it this is a huge historic
moment a big story that they need to be
on top of
I think they might finally starting to
be waking up to it because of what
happened in El Paso this week why this
week we had that huge migrant Caravan
come in on Sunday night the city of El
Paso is completely overwhelmed right now
there's hundreds of migrants homeless
living on the streets in the cold the
facilities are overwhelmed border patrol
is overwhelmed they're calling in Agents
from elsewhere
um it's it's a bad situation in El Paso
right now and that's where most of the
media is gone but hey the more the
merrier when it comes to this coverage
it's a big issue it has been a big issue
and Fox News has been covering it the
whole time and we're grateful for all
your work thank you Bill
hey it's Will Kane click here to
subscribe to the Fox News Channel on
YouTube it's the best way to get our
latest interviews and highlights and
click to subscribe to the will Kane
podcast for full episodes right now